every second that you spend you're
spinning away from
the development of these people that you
brought here that you love more than
anything in the world
so
what are you going
what are you going to spend that time on
so
that changed a lot jay-z reveals how
fatherhood changed his career and the
music mogul is giving unexpected insight
into his life as a dad reckless with
your time before you just
you know all over the place and then you
know you have to
what are you leaving your house for
you know like every second that you
spend you're spinning away from
the development of these people that you
brought here that you love
more than anything in the world so
what are you going
what are you going to spend that time on
so
that changed a lot i changed
practically everything in a rare
interview jay sits down with kevin hart
for season two of heart to heart the
grammy winner opens up about
prioritizing his three kids blue ivy
roomie and sir carter over his music
time is all you have that's the only
thing we control
how you spend your time baby i paint the
sky blue
my greatest creation was you it's simple
for hope he enjoys taking breaks from
work to spend time with his kiddos but
kevin asked if this means jay is putting
down the mic for good hold
are you retired
um
no i
you know i did i i tried that i'm
terrible with that i was about to say i
found one thing you announced it yeah
you announced it yeah you said i'm
retired yeah you made the world say oh
[ __ ] damn farewell i just needed a break
okay i'm not actively making music or
making an album or have plans to make an
album but i never want to say i'm
retired i just you know it's a gift and
who am i to shut it off jay-z is a man
who wears many hats as a businessman
producer and rapper who often collabs
with his wife beyonce
ready
and queen bee shared in her homecoming
documentary how she relates to jay and
finds it hard to give fans her all when
she wants to be with their little ones
it's my first time back home
on the stage
after giving birth
i'm creating my own homecoming
in the beginning it was so many muscle
spasms and just internally my body was
not connected my mind was not there my
mind wanted to be with my children
what people don't see is the sacrifice
one thing's for sure j and b are super
dedicated parents i think there's a
level of connection and foundation that
is so strong and i'm very happy and we
love to see rare moments of the carter
stepping out
back with us in the bay and here at
chase center tonight
just last month the rapper had an
adorable daddy daughter date with 10
year old blue at the nba championship
game and well blue got a little shy
especially since her dad messed up her
curls on the jumbotron the one and only
jay-z
it's priceless moments like this that
make us understand why the carters are
all about family first
selfishly fans want to keep the music
coming last year jay-z told et why he
loves working with his wife queen bee
she's a
super um
detail-oriented obviously as you can see
from her work and she's uh incredibly
hard worker
super talented
um very inspiring tell the grammys
have you ever seen a crowd going a
[Music]